des tombes creusées les unes à la suite
des autres pour enterrer les victimes du
coc vite 19 des images éloquentes qui
montre une vérité très éloignés des
chiffres officiels de la pandémie au
yémen à peine plus de 5600 cas confirmés
de coronavirus depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire et seulement quelques
dizaines de cas quotidiens comptabilisés
en plein pic épidémique
d'après l'onu ces statistiques ne
constituent en rien le reflet de la
réalité
en cause notamment le manque de test
dans un pays ravagé par la guerre et
dont les structures hospitalières n'ont
pas les capacités pour répondre à
l'urgence sanitaire
même avec l'arrivée des vaccins les
vaccins ne suffiront pas à venir à bout
de la deuxième vague
nous avons donc un besoin urgent de plus
de ressources pour intensifier le
traitement la surveillance et d'autres
activités qui atténueront l'impact de la
pandémie
et quand ce ne sont pas les capacités du
système de santé qui sont montrés du
doigt les pouvoirs publics prennent le
relais il ya de la négligence de la part
des autorités
ils n'ont pas rempli correctement leur
rôle lors de la vague précédente
le gouvernement avait pris des mesures
préventives même si elles n'étaient pas
suffisantes pour faire face à la
catastrophe
cette deuxième vague est plus intense
que la vague précédente mais les
autorités officielles de thaïs ou n'ont
pas rempli leur devoir de protéger la
tige
quand les tombes individuelles ne
suffisent plus les responsables des
cimetières en sont réduits à solliciter
l'aide des habitants pour creuser des
fosses communes
dix corps par jour nous sommes allés
chercher des fossoyeurs au marché pour
nous aider car nous pouvions pas
répondre à la demande de nouvelles
tombes et malgré le raid n'arrivions pas
à y faire face nous avons donc dû louer
une pelleteuse pour creuser de nouvelles
tombes et enterrées les victimes hier un
fossoyeur accroché et on pour autant de
corps enterrés alors que les nations
unies considèrent la situation au yémen
comme la pire crise humanitaire au monde
à l'heure actuelle la pandémie ne fait
qu'empirer les choses
depuis le début du conflit en 2014 au
moins deux cent cinquante mille
personnes ont perdu la vie